i was asleep i mean i was fasting
knocked out man
god [ __ ] woke me i said god
god why you making my black ass up this
is one of my favorite
scenes in the movie paul's character
right here is
he's telling us he's had a conversation
with god and along with this
being one of my favorite scenes is one
of my favorite cues
from the brilliant composer terence
blanchard
and in a minute you're going to see
paul's eyes
look away and that is the cue
for the camera to leave
boom right there camera
is leaving paul and going up into the
heavens
now this light you're about to see on
our late brother
chadwick bowles look at that look at
that that's not that was not lit
that was god's heavenly light blessing
chadwick and he comes this
this scene right here here's a ghost
but he's not lit here that is god's
heavenly life
please that was beautiful man it's one
of my it's one of my favorite scenes i
just
and it's amazing you say that because
when i first saw it i kept saying man
the way he lit this scene was amazing
and this part of the the film
to watch paul with his struggles
throughout the entire film
man was just such a culminating moment
to understand why
he was having his boots and delroy's
performance man first of all
that montage when he's looking into the
camera oh my god
his performance is just amazing you know
i remember because i remember when you
sent me the film i literally was like
quaking in my
zone this is like the five seconds left
in the game on a fast break with michael
jordan then he
passes you off you can't miss that shot
bro you can't miss that shot
delroy let me ask you a question when
you
speaking into the camera and then
you looked over did you see chadwick in
that god light that heavenly light
i did i did what's been interesting
about discussing this
in retrospect all the things we've come
to appreciate spike
and terrence about this work
i cannot tell you that in the moment i
was aware of any of that
right but to answer your question spike
yes i did
i i saw chadwick i saw norm
[Music]
[Applause]
you gave us the freedom spike to
roll with whatever was going to happen
and
this is an example of chadwick was in
his corner doing his prep
i was in my corner doing my prep and
when you said action
we came together and this is the result
man but delroy
man your performance right here i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna tell you this
man as a composer bro you broke me down
in my studio
working on this because this right here
this moment right here terence you got
broke down in the studio how do you
think i felt
right to be right there
this is the heartbreaking scene oh my
god because
for paul to break down like this now we
start to understand we start to
really realize what his struggle through
life has been man and
this movement and and he and here's the
thing about
it for me that made it real and i was
trying to tell it to somebody
the way spike and you guys put this film
together you brought our culture into it
because when patrick says
come on now you got me now bruh
that's like something you know my uncles
would say we you know
and that's what that's the universal we
good
we're good you know what i mean yeah and
bruh that got me
it look all of this man it was
it's one of those moments where i'm like
let me lock the door to the sea i need
nobody coming in here while i'm working
on
this because it's just a powerful moment
[Music]
i know you blood
[Music]
i died for your blood and another thing
i'd like to add
very rare do you see black men like this
yeah or vulnerable yes showing love for
each
other brotherhood right
love sympathy
yes empathy this scene his character
storming norman
is a ghost but he's came
back to tell his brother
who has had to live
with this burden that in a friendly fire
he kills stormy norman and installer
norman
has come back to tell him it's all right
right come on now it's all right come on
you're gonna be good
you know you
he took the burden off his shoulders is
that that scene
is about i know somebody might say
universal love but i'm gonna say
black love right there black
man black male love which we don't see a
lot of
i'm not trying to say that's the only
thing's ever been done
i'm not saying that i would never say
that
but this is example of that to me
and also uh forgiveness
when you see these men coming together
with the ability norm
who says it's all right man it's okay
forgiveness
which is um which is gargantuan
audiences do not get to see ordinarily
black men exhibiting those kinds of
feelings
for each other tenderness tenderness
tenderness
but listen just just to step away from
that one second
technically what's one of the other
things that's extraordinary
about this work for me is that
technically this was chadwick's first
day of work um
this is the very first this is the first
time that chadwick and i are playing
are playing together by the time
chadwick came
we were five or six weeks into filming
working
and i had met chadwick chadwick briefly
two days later we were filming this
scene
which i know right huh
yeah i will never ever ever ever um
my my appreciation for um
chadwick as a as a worker
obviously i had seen him in black
panther
um 42 but the fact that he could come
and lock in he bring it man he brung it
but he speaks to all you guys downright
that's that's the thing about this
piece that i think has gone unspoken man
that ensemble cast was crazy
you know what i mean man i was telling
somebody i said listen bro i worked on
this thing
i go through these scenes over and over
and of course spike is editing and
putting together and he's directing it
i'm sitting there watching it going man
what a collection of brilliant talent
you know
in this film when i of course we know
clark
isaiah all of these guys and then your
your performance
just like put it over the top and i'm
telling you that's why i made the
analogy about basketball i was joking
about it but literally
when i got it i because you know the
people have been asking me about it and
i said look man spike told me
he was going to shoot this film right
after the oscars and i was like damn
dude
take a break what you know what i mean
you you earned it and he's like no he
was on a plane the next day
and i'm sitting right yeah and i'm
sitting there going coming off a black
classman
what is he going to do and that's when
he sent me the video and i saw you guys
performance
i told my wife i told everybody i said
oh my god he's done it again
i said you know in a deep profound and
beautiful way
because the thing that i loved about the
performance bro
is is is that you know
you guys did it was never lost
throughout the entire film
that you guys were professional soldiers
even though we're seeing you as
older guys and chadwick as being you
know the younger version
you know but when when we looked at you
guys it was never lost
on me just because of the way you
carried yourself and your characters
that you were professional soldiers
fighting for our freedoms
in that moment or the mlk assassination
bro that was another moment that got me
to think that you guys are putting your
lives on the line
and not getting that kind of support
back at home and now you're telling me
that this is younger man
that's another great cue thank you thank
you thank you thank you
but now you're telling me this young man
just jumped in there like that because
see
because for me when i watch that scene
i'm sitting i'm sitting and thinking to
myself
okay that's the culmination of them
being out there shooting this thing
together
and now you told me that was his first
day was he said that was brother man's
first
day of work you know spike and i have
talked
this project man was touched this was
touched by
this project was touched by god oh you
can see that man you can see that
spike assembled all the pieces
he brought us all together and then
in addition to all of that there were
instances
throughout the process where god just
said
go ahead that's for y'all come on come
on that's
yeah i mean because people look bro
we've romanticized war and conflict to
the point
where people don't really understand
what they're likely about
you know what i mean and that's the
thing that i've i found
interesting about the portrayal of these
characters between delroy clark isaiah
roddy you know we we we
we we are convinced that these guys were
in that world
just by the way they carry themselves
with their character so terence you said
um when you speak about the fact that
you said you never for one second
you always believed that they were these
were professional
soldiers yes right the fact that you
always believed that we
were who we were supposed to be in this
narrative
narrative is the testament to this
coming together
of the professionalism of who these men
are as
actors and their dedication to the work
to the craft and the dedication that we
um developed
towards each other in the work
and i've said it countless times the
the beautiful thing about that
dedication that we had toward each other
was that it was never ever discussed
it happened organically and so now
we take um the connection
and the vibe that we have off screen
because we're staying in the same hotel
we're writing the set
back to and from set together and we're
talking we're just commuting
all the time all the time for two and a
half months and we take
we take that energy this off screen
and we bring it to the work that we're
doing
in front of the camera and that results
in you
terence for instance as as as audience
saying
i always believed that you were who you
said you were
what you know what more what more can an
actor ask for
no and let me just tell you this too not
only did i believe it
one of the things that you made me do as
a composer
is feel for the for those guys who
fought for our freedoms and didn't get
any recognition
so you know that's what i try to do with
that music
is to try to pay homage to those guys
you know what i mean like
yeah we need to kill them as heroes man
you know because they came back not to
the heroes welcome
you know not so unfortunate because you
were putting your life on the line for
us amen
it was so much bigger than all of us
we then we then just became the conduits
through which this uh communication this
communique was being
was being put together and you know what
spike
terence this is i've never had an
experience like this
this is like what i mean by that it's
almost like
the gift that just keeps on giving it
just keeps on giving
because every time we talk to um
whomever it may be
press audiences students aspiring
filmmakers
fellow actors they all connect to
various aspects of this project and
speak
on how hit how it has impacted them
and i've ended up saying um cumulatively
i mean i've ended up saying you know
what
this is why i went to acting school work
like this
school days whatever the case may be
can open up the audience's brains to a
new to new possibilities
of course but think about that's what
work he's supposed to do
and look i'm gonna close with this door
when you guys were doing
shooting the five bloods right i'm
always accustomed to what spike is gonna
do because i know he always sends me
stuff
back that's like from america cnn i was
looking out like man this is just
amazing
dude word was coming back to me from
people that was working on the set
delroy's doing his thing that was the
common refrain
from people that was there devil was
doing this thing and then i got the
video
and i went oh my god yeah bro so
i'm if it took 25 years and uh
maybe it was just 25 years of just
working up to this moment bro
that means everything time is everything
it was the right time
amen amen i love you guys god bless you
all
all right peace and love